Yeah.
So moving four were beds
and cubads will be foundational computational paradise
with which we can tackle
complex problems in the world
so let's try to understand the difference between them
and where the power of cubits rise
if we look at the left hand side
it's a way to describe and we're going to use these diagrams
are throughout the presentation to
impact the power we're seen a circle
and two dots when the circle when the dot is in the north poll
that the zero when it's in the south pole is a one
that's a classical bit to state now a cubit is the
unit of information in quantum world
and here we get to have with the picture
as as fear as zero no one
and we can have them in this superposition state
we have a special trick that is available to us
not only we can have them position in this fear
but imagine that each one of this
now is like a little moon
that is in this fear and we can rotate the moon
so here you're seeing that
the bottom sphere has been rotated slightly
so that's why you see a little bit of blue
and pink and we could rotate it all the way
so here's a hundred and eighty degree shift
so we have these notion of face quantum affords us
three super powers that are exhibited in the cubans
they are the powers of super position
the power of interference
and the power of entanglement
so let's impact those the principle of superposition is actually
quite straight forward to understand
so the star on the left hand side
we are for north poll zero or south pole one
and if we add those two states
now we have a super position cubit that has both
zero and a one simultaneously north
and softball now the right diagram is the same
but now we're going to do a little trick
we're gonna play a gate a quantum gate
on what we did here is remember
we get to change now we get to
rotate these little moons right
so we've rotated it a hundred
and eighty degrees and now we have a one
so now when we do the addition of zero plus one we end up
with a super position state
but notice that is different
and the one on the left we are
still a zero no one but now with a rotated state
for the one now that is going to be very powerful
to then leverage a second really interesting thing which is
the principle of interference
and this is not an operation that we get to perform in classical
bid world so here in this example we have
a zero no one on the left plus
this new state that we created
which is also zero no one
but with this rotated moon when we do this now
we get to interfere those two states
and notice something real interesting happened
we've cancelled the one state
and we've ended up with that zero state
we've done that because we interfere the states
so the next opportunity that we have right now
is how many states can we create
and the beautiful thing in quantum is we get to create an exponential
number of states so let's look at a system that has
five cubits in this case we're depicting these cubans
as independent cubans right you're seeing them on the left
zeros on ones and they're getting multiplied we have five
of them so the number of states that we can create down or
quantum computer depicted on this fear on the right
it's too to the power of
the number of cubits we have in this case we are five
so two to the power five is thirty two states
so we're seeing thirty two of those little moons
notice that in these case we did not incorporate
any face they're all pink the powerful aspect of
using this property calling tanglement in the quantum world
he's that we can create now states
like the one depicted on the right
where we have these combinations of pink
and do where that's and state cannot be described
as the independent product off
these five cubits in this case
since we have thirty two states
with this tells us is actually something very profound